FAUCI ERA ICIALLY
FAUCI IS THEE  VILLAIN.
>> GROHY FAUCI.
>> DOOGLM,FLIP-FLOFAUCI.
GOP LAWMAKE ET
TACKWING THE FACK LOOP
INEFCTSTF
AR T PROPAGANDA  WEA ORAT MEDIA.
POLITICIAN THAAUCI'SER
SHOWS HE'S AFFILIATED WI NO
PARTY.
HE'S WORKED ND AN PW E A REPUBLN
BOOGEYMAN.
FAUCI SAID ONE THING Y AN PRIVA
GROWING EVIDENCE FOUCH WAUCI WA
WARNED
>> EE SEEN THI
?AXIOS CALLTRUMS NEW
A FREE DPOOF INF
REQUREVEALED MARCH F
EXIVE TIES TO N
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY THANKS R L
THE ORIGIN IS STILL BEING PROBED
BY THE BDMINISTRATIOD
SAYING THAT BAD
HIS S WAY  COMMENTS. TH LIKELIN
SAME TIM KEE
MIND BB
LEAK.
A MIND, WHAT ANON
THESE GOAKERS MINDE
Y CALLAURO
MORE
D. LD GO.
FAUCI HAS BLOOD ON HI
CONSISTENTLY FROM THE VERYG HAVR
R PEOPLE
TH BAC>> ANDHA
K FOR HIM SELVE
SELVESL FIND A PLACE ON
CO WALREHEY TRYING TEM
ING THE
PANDEMIC F BIGGER
WITH ME FROM THE BULWARK A
AMANDA CARP ENTER ANS
V LEGITIMATE SIPP HE PAN
HEE  THE .E CLOSED EVEN LEA
THEORYANIN I D F HMESSEN BE HASH
ABOUMAE HE WANTED TO PE  RESPOA.
I THINK WHEN HE KES THAT
DEFENSHA
R, T MS.
SOMEONE AND OTHER THING IKTHIN
HAS BROOD ON HANIS SORT OFT YOU
THESE DAYS.
>> AND THEN A Y
LAND BECAUSE T
TO HPEAND IT
IS THE BIGGER UR WHE
ATTACKS DON'T STICK, FOX
WORLD FINDS NEW TARGETS.E YOU W
ALACRY
OBSESSION OFMEA AND
SO THAT IS AN EXAMPLE OFG TO >T
IF YOU DO WATCH FOX ANPAY NTION
LOOKING  TARGETS.
ITT BIDEN, IT
AFTEITICAL RACE ANI D LIKE SHOU
BE DEBATEDN GOOD
CCOULD BE A.
BUT E E THAT IN THESE  I
RIABOUCKING AN
CONDUCIVE TO A GOOD DE. ELL, A S
>> WL, LISTEN, IT IS BRYLAHINK
THE CONSERVATIS T
TO ML
CURRICULUM.KE WE'VE HAD UPROARS
E INCLUSN WHEN IT
S
VEOT CRITICACETHEORY IS G N
E IS  DISCUSSION OFE.
AND SO I THINKN REGULAR
HIS  T BLA DANG
THEORY BEINGDOPTED THAT
TEACHES YOUR CHIRE
OTHERS, THEY SORT OFE IT
ITON.
HEAD,CAL RA G I
THEORY AND TRANSGENDER
BATHRO THAVE A IN THE PAN QUALI.
>> I HEAR PEOPLE SAYINT UTACACAH
T SHE GO TO TH AND THAT WEEKS E
MOVED OVER ITH OF THE
A ICO
ANEMA,
ANOTR AMALA IST M WELL IN TH
R
BUS ON FAGAIMONIZE HER
BOUT YR
THAMERICANONDER AND
BO
S EVERY HOUR TRELOOKTO
NOT BIDEN BUHER.RYR TO CR ON T
REALLY JUS
MEDIA IN PLACES A
THIS MEDIA MISSTEP THAHEISSUES.H
K OF "HOAX" AND
AT I WAS HEARINGM L VO
SHE SAID THE TEAMS THAT NOT THE
HE RIGHTG A RRDETION, TH RAT KNE
>> I JUST FOX.
ROE TRUME
A HU GHT WING
A IN DESPETH
CRT OD THEYRTHER TO THE
RIGHT AND IT IS JUST -- SORT OI.
>> NOW HERE ISOSINTERE
STORY THAT I READ SS WORLD.
CNBC RHAT WHILE LOCK LAN
RUNNI
JAMES MURDOCH HAS BEEN DONATINM
OF DOLLARS.
$100 MILLI FM
INL CAUSES AND THERE EVEN IRE
TO  THIS
AND NOT HEAR T FRO
CCESON
IS THAT WH TS STORY IS
IT AND HE'S USINGONEY
E FOX MONEY TO UNDO
TH REMARKABL
USE FOX MONEY TO
O SOME OWH
IN PLACEH ISG.
>>CTLY.
ANWEING TO SEE MORE AND
MORE OF  FROM JAMES MUOC
AND THIS IS FR, BEFORE
THD WHAT'SG CONGRESS
BECA TSETIRU T
BUT OLIVER, THATINBUSINESS INTE?
>> I.
AND SO TU E G BIG TECHE ITIMATC
BUITFFICUL IGNOR PLACE INTO HI
H AND GETTKEN UPN YOU SEE THX
OR THE " SL," IT
IS DIFFICULT.
>> THINK A WN
BUT AMANDA, AT THE SAME TIME
THERE IS AS
THE MARKABLE AND
>> AND THEY HAVEBOUT